KATY
Hey, can we get real for a second?
We've been friends for ten years.
I know that you don't
like to talk about your life...
But a guy with a freakin' machete for
an arm just chopped our bus in half!
♫ ["Run It" by DJ Snake
feat. Rick Ross and Rich Brian] ♫
KATY
Who are you?
♫ (Run it) Only talkin'
Makin' major moves ♫
SHANG-CHI
My father trained me to be
the Ten Rings' greatest weapon.
♫ On the road to riches
I could never lay around ♫
SHANG-CHI
But that's not who I am.
♫ Me against the world
I got my back against the wall ♫
SHANG-CHI
How did you find me?
WENWU
I always know where my children are.
♫ Me against the world
I got my back against the wall ♫
KATY
Seems like a nice fella.
♪♪
SHANG-CHI
It's time to show the world...
♫ Know I'm hell bound
But I'm well now ♫
SHANG-CHI
...who I really am.
♫ No one will ever stop me ♫
♫ Everybody scream
Everybody scream ♫
♫ That's my only thing, yes
I'm a born winner ♫
SHANG-CHI
Come on!
♪ A Jordan 23 (Woo!) ♪
KATY
Oh, hell no! I'm not doing that!
♪♪
YING NAN
You are a product of all
who came before you.
♫ (Gun it) I bought a 'Rari and I did it
Just to hear the sound ♫
♫ Drive safe really 'bout to
Lose all its meaning now ♫
SHANG-CHI
If I die, it's your fault.
♫ Say you're married to the game
And I'm just here to burn the gown ♫
SHANG-CHI
I must stop him.
KATY
Hell yeah.
♫ Around with homies like we run the city
Lookin' fresh and feelin' like a milli ♫
♫ Move in silence you can never hear me
If you got a problem when you see me ♫
♫ Bang, tryna show you
What we came to do ♫
♫ Boss, only talkin',
Makin' major moves ♫
SHANG-CHI
My name is Shang-Chi.
KATY
Shawn Chee.
- Shang.
- Shun.
SHANG-CHI
S-H-A-N-G. Shang.
KATY
That's what I said.
Oh, you're gonna turn it up?
Yeah, you can hear me.
♫ Run it ♫